[Music]
one time I was hooking up kissing with
this guy you know after I was just
laying next to him was thinking okay I'm
a board suck a little dick or
something I wonder if that's a
commentary on his
presentation and so I do and I'm
thinking to do uh and I'm thinking to do
his reaction I guess I'm good at this
okay nice little humble brag there and I
guess because you know he's screaming or
whatever I'm good at the I guess because
you know as I'm sucking a little dick or
something he's
going and I think oh I might be good at
this and he's about to
nut and he is about to nut I saw his
head go back slack oh you killed him
holy [__] so I'm thinking I'm a God at
this point but no his leg starts
spasming mouth foaming seizure he had
epilepsy there's more to the end but
that's the gist of it see I appreciate
this oh man I appreciate this makes me
never want to touch a man again yo him
having epilepsy from head is that cuz
you were blowing him with like Kanye
glass is
on were you wearing a headband with some
LEDs in it that'd be wild if you never
looked up and you're just you know
you're going to work and you're thinking
oh God I am slay queen I am slaying this
[__] this is an absolute slay look at
his legs and they're just
[__]
just modulating his epilepsy with his
little dick like a joystick his legs
going up down left right you're like
damn slay queen I'm killing this and
then this [__] just back there
just looking like he's chewing on
Alka-Seltzer man that dude has a
trigger that dude has a trigger in his
penis orgasm induced seizures a rare
phenomena oh oh yeah I like this little
science a variety of stimuli can cause
reflex seizures some triggers include
light music and cognitive
phenomena there are case reports however
where the phenomenon of sexual activity
has been a trigger for epileptic
seizures most of these cases reported
are in women so far oh so you're saying
it's
possible and were found to be localized
to uh right cerebral
hemisphere we report a case of a
36-year-old male with orgasm induced
seizures with other atypical features
compared to a majority of previous
reports
interesting this is the abstract let's
continue reflex seizures are well-known
entities developing in response to a
discreet or specific stimulus reflex
seizures are the ones that quote
objectively and consistently are
demonstrated to be evoked by a specific
affrant stimulus or by the activity of
the
patient affrant stimuli can be
Elementary that is unstructured such as
light flashes and startle oh so you
could just you could scare someone into
a seizure oh like the fainting goat
oh that's crazy man if you didn't know
you had that and your friends are like
let's go to a haunted
house afron stimuli can be elaborate
that is structured activity may be
Elementary airgo motor a movement or
elaborate airgo cognitive reading and
chess playing you can get a seizure from
playing
chess or both as an example reading
aloud no well be
careful photosensitive epilepsy is the
most con
photosensitive epilepsy is the
most all right no that's not funny
that's not funny I'm sorry I'm sorry
photosensitive epilepsy is the most
common type of this epilepsy reflex
seizures have a 5 to 6% prevalence among
patients with
epileps in patients with reflex seizures
probably there are probably there are
regions of cortical
hyperexcitability that's what I'm going
to refer to the bottom of my head head
as this is a region of cortical
hyperexcitability that overlap if you're
uncut with areas activated during
sensory
stimulations when this part gets
activated in response to a reflex
stimulus it may lead to partial or
generalized seizures sexual orgasm is
now recognized as a stimulus for reflex
epilepsy according to the international
league against epilepsy there's a league
fighting
epilepsy
wow International
League we are the
ilae seizures evoked by sexual orgasms
were the first were first reported in
1960 followed by few more case reports
dude 1960 what was medicine like in 1960
must have been pretty decent I was
picturing bringing your [__] caved
partner and you're like I don't know
those scary time as a woman bringing a
male body to the doctor and you're like
oh gosh no you're it's 1960s so you're
were like yes I was sucking his [__]
see yeah we were around the backside of
the McDonald's and I sucked my husband's
[__] in the backseat of our Buick and he
started bubbling up like salt on a snail
and I thought gee I better bring him by
the dock to set him
right who's the
presidential wife that was given the
crazy
head n was it Nancy Pelosi
rean
Reagan man Lauren [__] hit the Family
Feud button on that
one Nancy
Reagan maybe that's why seizures were
first reported in the 1960s cuz Nancy
Reagan was [__] goating that throat
you
know did you imagine just blowing uh I
don't
know uh who's that
dude Lyndon B
Johnson that guy unironically supposedly
had a huge
dong he complained about uh uh jeans
being too tight he's like they how to
make the bottom area lower so your dick
and balls canang in there
Nancy Reagan killed Lyndon B
Johnson what a name for a dude with a
huge Hammer Lynden B
Johnson
fire
fire yeah that's when they were first
reported Nancy Reagan giving that
[__]